When Apple announced that you can now get
an 8-core processor in the new 2019 MacBook
Pro, the first thought that came into everyone’s
mind is that “It’s definitely gonna thermal
throttle if the 6-core MacBook Pro did.
So we’re gonna find out if that’s true
by running our classic Cinebench stress test
on both the new MacBook Pro with the 2.3GHz
8-core processor, 32gigs of RAM and Vega 20
graphics, as well as on our similarly configured
and priced 2018 model with the 2.6GHz 6-core
i7 processor.
$3549.00each
The reason it’s not the 6-core i9 processor
is because we literally saw zero gains in
video editing compared to the i7, and we expect
the same results with the new 8-core, hence
why we didn’t pay an extra $200 for the
faster 8-core processor.
What we’re gonna do is run Cinebench R20
five times back-to-back to ensure that the
system heats up and the fans stabilize the
temps, then we’ll compare the average score
to the 2018 model.
Shortly after starting our first run, the
CPU boosts up to 4.39GHz, nowhere near the
advertised 4.8GHz turbo boost speed, which
isn’t a surprise because that number is
rated off just one core out of 8 running by
itself with temps under 50 degrees celsius.
The clock speed then lowers down to around
3.3GHz just before the temps reach 99 degrees.
As soon as this happens, the wattage drops
to 60, the temps instantly shoot down to 90
degrees, and the clock speed is now sticking
to around 3.0GHz.
The temp slowly starts picking up again and
stays at around 97 degrees while the clock
speed hovers around 2.9 GHz until we finish
the first run with a score of 3096, before
instantly rerunning the test again.
Just for comparison, the $5000 base iMac Pro
scores around 3,700 in this test.
Starting the second run, the CPU spikes to
a lower 4.31GHz before coming back down to
the same 2.9GHz clock speed range.
Unlike the first run, the fans are now at
full blast, so it’s able to keep the clock
speed higher at around 3.0GHz at the same
97 degrees temp range, now finishing with
an even higher 3161 score.
Starting the third run, the CPU spikes up
to only 3.65GHz, showing the effect temps
have on turbo boost speeds.
Now here we notice something very interesting,
the clock speed is able to stay at around
3GHz while the temps are sitting at a lower
94 to 95 degrees, but out of nowhere, the
CPU clocks down to 2.9GHz even though it doesn’t
need to, since the temps aren’t too high.
In fact, they go as low as 91 degrees, with
plenty of thermal headroom for faster clock
speeds, but it doesn’t ever go above 3.0GHz,
almost like it’s being intentionally limited.
If it is, maybe it’s due to very careful
thermal management to make sure it gets the
most performance out of the processor, or
there’s always the chance that the 2.4GHz
CPU for $200 more allows the clock speeds
to go up a little bit higher under load, but
who knows.
Back to the test, the third run finishes with
an impressive 3125 score.
The 4th run spikes up to 3.7GHz turbo boost,
so it seems like the system’s thermals have
stabilized.
We can now see that the temperature stays
at 93 degrees while at 2.9GHz and at 95 degrees
while at 3.0GHz, now completely stabilized.
The fourth run scored 3154 points, and the
fifth scored 3147, making for a 5-run average
score of 3,136.
Now before we draw some conclusions and thoughts
from this, let’s quickly talk about the
results from the 2018 MacBook Pro.
Basically every single run hit around 4.03-4.04GHz
peak turbo boost before coming down to around
3.1-3.3GHz before finally stabilizing at around
3.04-3.08GHz at temps ranging from around
96-97 degrees, and interestingly, we didn’t
see temps randomly going down to 91 or 92
degrees like we did on the 2019 Pro.
Each run was also very consistent and scored
exactly 2425 points every time.
Comparing both of them, we see that the 2019
model hit a much higher 4.39GHz turbo boost,
but the stabilized clock speed was lower at
around 2.9-3.0GHz compared to 3.04-3.08GHz.
However, the stabilized temps were lower staying
between 93 and 95 degrees compared to 96 and
97 degrees.
This shows us that Apple decided to keep the
temps a bit lower on the new model instead
of slightly turning up the power to hit around
97 degrees.
I read through some forums and some users
mentioned that the high heat of previous MacBook
Pros could have been wearing down the components
in the butterfly keyboard, so if that’s
true, it would make sense why Apple would
want the temps to stay lower, and it could
actually fix the keyboard problems once and
for all.
The best part is that even though temps were
lower than they could’ve been, we still
got an average score that’s 30% higher than
the 2018 MacBook Pro.
So we get more power, with cooler temps, at
the same price.
Snazzy Labs tested the new 8-core MacBook
Pro and he found that Apple seems to have
set a full load clock speed target, where
instead of turning up the clock speed whenever
there’s extra thermal headroom, the machine
would slow down the fans for a quieter experience.
He also replaced the thermal paste with liquid
metal and didn’t find much of a difference,
stating that the 2019 MacBook Pro features
much better thermal paste than previous MacBook
Pros.
This definitely shows in our testing, as the
2019 MacBook Pro idled at only 35 degrees
celcius compared to 45 degrees with the 2018
model, now that’s a huge difference.
We also tested Cinebench R20 using a single
thread to see the difference in performance
and we saw that the 2019 Pro hit a maximum
of 4.5GHz turbo boost compared to 4.17 on
the 2018 Pro, and we scored 466 points compared
to 422.
So not only do we get 2 extra cores, but each
core is faster as well.
So let’s answer our original question, the
2019 8-core MacBook Pro obviously thermal
throttles, right?
No, it actually fixes the throttling issues
from before, performing much better while
at lower temps, which may possibly even fix
the keyboard issues at the same time.
If you’re thankful that we ran these tests
and you’re thinking of buying a 2019 MacBook
Pro for yourself, smash that like button and
use the links in the description to help support
this channel.
Make sure you’re subbed by clicking the
circle above and check out one of those two
videos.
Thanks for watching, and we’ll see you in
the next one.